da
warm
episode 2 valentinstag
was gibt es heute zum abendessen
zur vorspeise gibt es salat
ich mag keinen salat
ein bisschen musst du essen salat ist
gesund ein bisschen musst du essen salat
ist gesund
ihr geht
zum hauptgang habe ich eine pizza
gebacken
ich hasse kochen
ich hoffe kochen
oh nein die pizza ist verbrannt
ich rufe den pizza kurier an
guten
abend hier ist pizza pizza pedro am
apparat
guten abend hier ist pizza pizza pedro
am apparat
guten abend hier ist schröder
ich möchte gerne eine pizza bestellen
ja guten abend hier ist schröder
hallo frau schröder ist ihnen wieder
einmal eine pizza verbrannt
ja kochen ist nicht meine stärke
welche plätze darf es denn heute sein
welche pizza darf es denn heute sein
ich hätte gerne eine pizza margherita
und eine familien pizza hawaii
gerne darf es sonst noch etwas sein
gerne darf es
noch etwas sein
nein danke das ist alles
ok
wie ist ihre adresse
ok wie ist ihre adresse
wir wohnen an der hauptstraße 27 in
neben statt
wir wohnen an der hauptstraße 27
innenstadt
wie lange dauert es etwa
wir liefern ihnen die bestellung in etwa
30 minuten
super sie sind meine rettung
danke schön und auf wiederhören
und als süße nachspeise gibt es
apfelkuchen
und als diese nachspeise gibt es
lecker
guten appetit
bald ist der valentinstag
ich
wer den salat hoffentlich gut versteckt
ich habe den salat hoffentlich gut
versteckt
eure mutter und ich haben uns verabredet
und ihr seid denn alleine zu hause
und ihr seid dann alleine zu hause
sturmfrei sturmfrei
120 kinder
ich erzähle euch jetzt eine unglaubliche
geschichte
kinder ich erzähle euch jetzt eine
unglaubliche geschichte
sie handelt davon wie ich eure mutter
kennengelernt habe
sagen wir für etwas bestraft werden
wir für etwas bestraft werden
nein ist es eine lange geschichte
ist es eine lange geschichte
ja vor 5
jahren habe ich ein ganz anderes leben
geführt
ja vorfällen
jahren habe ich ein ganz anderes leben
geführt
[Musik]
ich habe zahnschmerzen
zahnschmerzen
ich mag
einen termin beim zahnarzt vereinbaren
ich muss einen termin beim zahnarzt
vereinbaren
zahnarztpraxis am hauptplatz müller
guten tag hier ist schröder ich habe
starke zahnschmerzen und brauche
dringend einen termin
guten tag
hier ist schröder ich habe starke
zahnschmerzen und brauche dringend einen
termin
ok morgen um 8 uhr 30 ist noch einen
termin frei
geht ihnen das
ok morgen um 8 uhr 30 ist noch einen
termin frei
geht ihnen das
meine schmerzen sind aber so groß haben
sie keinen termin mehr frei für heute
meine schmäh
das sind aber so groß haben sie keinen
termin mehr frei für heute
ich sehe gerade das ein termin abgesagt
wurde
können sie heute um 16 uhr 30
ich sehe gerade das ein termin abgesagt
wurde
können sie heute um 16 30
ja danke und bis gleich ja danke und bis
gleich
ich muss dir sind sahen 4
ich muss dir so einsam fühlen
der baule zahn
das ist der faule sau
danke sie sind bei einer retterin
danke sie sind meine retterin
er hat so schöne zähne
so
hätten wir uns auf einen kaffee so
verabredeten wir uns auf einen kaffee
und somit kinder ist das die wahre
geschichte wie ich eure tante rubin
kennengelernt habe
und somit kinder ist das die wahre
geschichte wie ich eure tante rubin
kennengelernt habe
tante ruby
ich dachte in der geschichte geht es um
mama
gar
ruhig dazu komme ich nach
ganz ruhig dazu komme ich nach
wie schon gesagt es ist eine lange
geschichte
[Musik]
habt ihr das video gefallen
ein leica und abonniere den kanal danke
[Musik]